So with sterling it's like sterling
called out Covington. Yeah. Garb. Rant.
Yeah.
I'm saying Colby Covington already
cause I'm already thinking that mother
Gamelin that marketing.
Yeah.
Well he's good at talking shit and getting
his name out there and it's the best
thing for the welterweight
division right now.
After it loose man just
dominated Tyron Woodley.
I was blown away by that fight me to
loan away. I were texting each other.
It's weird cause I had people around the
house to watch the fights and they were
like, God, this fight so boring. And I
look online like God, this is brutal.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
I was one of the greatest title fight
performances I've ever seen her forever to
do that to Woodley and dismantle him.
You don't understand.
You have no idea what you're watching.
It's fucking insane.
It's not just insane that he dismantled
them, which is for sure insane.
But also his fucking gas tank Uzman was
pushing on the pedal for five fucking
rounds.
Never let off the gas.
How about the way he looked in between
rounds when Dan and to me it was his
mentality. When you look from
the f, the first round she was,
they break it up and then you're ready
standing there like this. I'm like, oh,
he was, do you know that word was
that he had a fractured foot? Correct.
So he took a fucking cortisone shot coming
into that fight. Imagine that savage.
Imagine that and still no
problems with his endurance.
Apparently didn't train the whole
week of just didn't do shit.
Still made the weight. No problem.
But think about what he has to do.
His coach is gone. You got to go
in there. You got to out grapple.
How maneuvered Tyrone Woodley, who's one
of the best welterweights of all time?
Well he,
how does he get taken down?
Did empties and get taken dad who doesn't
get taken down? He also was kind of,
I dunno, he's 37 I don't know if it's,
he just didn't show up what happened.
But he's 36 [inaudible] 36 either way.
Same thing.
Either way he's been doing for a hot
second. This is why I feel bad for thing.
Maybe you know Joe,
but Woodley was always that guy
where he didn't get along with Dana.
He was kind of difficult to deal with,
did it his way and made some demands,
want the big fight and then it never
happened for him. Right. He just,
he was in a big draw and but he could get
away with that when he was champ right
now that he's not champ the road frame
to get back cause going to be so fucking
tough. Right. Because of what
he did when he was champ.
That's why I feel bad for Woodley and
he's one of the greatest to ever do it.
He is one of the greatest to ever do
it and I was making the argument before
this fight that he,
you could argue,
you could argue that if he beats Guzman
spawn, he is the greatest. Correct.
He's in the, the the greatest
is George Saint Pierre, right.
He was a legend at welterweight.
You, you look at his career,
I mean how many years
was George to champ for?
Was it six years or something crazy
that the most title. So you have George,
Matt Hughes and Woodley Matthews has
legend status because he was the original,
right?
He was,
I mean he was the first wrestler that
really developed rock solid submission
skills. The, the fights with frank
Trigg, the f I mean he, when he,
um, armbar George Saint Pierre and their
first fight, I mean he was amazing.
But then the new school was George,
you know,
George was the best
welterweight of all time,
but I was saying that d he's
in the running right now.
If you consider the opponents he beat
Wonderboy twice, knocks out Robbie Lawler,
the wind, the title, and then goes
on from there. Beats Damien Maia.
Um,
I mean you,
you look at how he beat Darren till
for some reason he was an underdog and,
and Darren till five,
which didn't make any sense to me.
I thought everybody got
excited. I got excited too. I
thought Dan is going to win.
That really? I did see, I thought Darren
tills very good, but I did not do much.
I never saw him on the ground.
I never saw a real wrestler take
him down and ground and pound.
I didn't know what he had off his bass.
He,
I think there until it can be a prompt
for Huseman what really is size.
Yeah. I think we see a problem and Dan
has committed to one seven. He still is.
He still, I think especially
now that one 70 cause what is,
if you are a fan of fighting,
what is fun is Woodley be an out
the welterweight division. So fun.